choosing to do a murder mystery as
a mission story it grew from something
that could have been very simple
into wouldn't it be cool if you could
actually solve the whole thing then it
kind of spun into this
little thing that doesn't necessarily
feel like the rest of the game anymore
please go ahead
my name is victor rasmussen uh i'm a
junior level designer on
hikma3 and i'm joking i am a
now lead level designer previously level
designer and i worked on the england
level on hitman 3 with victor
it's about coming home to the leader of
a shadowy
organization and everything about it is
set
in this mansion of mysteries there are
secret passages there's a murder mystery
underway and everything ties into this
old british mysterious mansion and the
people who inhibit it
i think there are many ways that we
start designing our levels there's
really a lot of disciplines coming
together
in many cases we start with a location
or an event
or or a target or premise like that in
this case we started with the premise of
wanting to create
a place that was home to a character we
wanted to get as close to the target as
possible we found out that this
british mansion was just really the way
to go
a mansion is a house and a house is home
right it just
it immediately communicated what it was
all gonna be about and then from that
point there was already the idea of
what if there was this murder mystery
kind of thing going on we didn't really
know what it was but it was always there
the direction of intimacy and being
close to the target was really strong
and it really guided us a lot in what
kind of
experience we wanted the player to have
it's this moment where like
all of alexa carlyle's family members
gather and you see the interactions
between them and
see what kind of character she is
choosing to do
a murder mystery as a mission story
had a few advantages it allowed us to
get very close
to the target it allowed us to have a
lot of dialogue that would uncover
backstory not just for the target but
for her family and thus at depth
to the location and to the target itself
it grew from something that could have
been very simple into
wouldn't it be cool if you could
actually solve the whole thing wouldn't
it be cool if this was not a linear
thing but you could go find clues
wouldn't it be cool if we
like tried to take our systems and then
use them in this different way
and then it kind of spun into this
little
thing that doesn't necessarily feel like
the rest of the game anymore
we have these routes that we try to make
the player go
the first time at least it's something
we often refer to as a 90 percenter the
thing that we want 90
of players to do the first time because
it will give them a good introduction to
the level before we just let you go nuts
of course you can just go nuts if you
want to right but it's usually a good
idea just to get this
understanding before this was tricky
because as you mentioned there were a
lot of elements that play right from the
onset
we knew we wanted to have the the
private investigator
clearly on screen very early and we
wanted to give you a chance to take his
outfit early because we wanted that to
be the 90
or solving the meta mystery because it
acts as a good introduction to that
level and then it spun into this
very different experience that we wanted
people to try out that
is phineas whitmer the famous private
investigator
hired by madame carla this morning we
also needed to have people talking about
what was going on on the devil because
there's a
main character who's victor of death but
then there's an open grave because she's
still having the fake funeral and then
there's a dead
you know brother in the in the upstairs
room and there's a private investigator
like someone needs to explain this to
the player
and and make it believable by making it
clear that it's also strange to the
people present
i know i ought to say anything but i'm
so relieved you're here
everything's just so strange preparing
for madame's funeral and then she turns
up alive
but then the awful business with her
brother zachary there was a lot of work
breaking this into believable
conversations grounded in the
environment and you mentioned this this
road and the gate and that
along that we actually built the ideal
path so the first thing you would see
would be the private investigator and
the guards and that gives some
exposition on who he is and why he's
there diana kicks in if you choose to
follow the mission story you get the
maid more exposition and then already
there
we start having like the path widens but
everything around that area
is is built to introduce you to the
level and the further you go
in the more details you get on what's
going on around
we use a lot of the classic level design
tricks
we try to put you in a situation where
if we want you to go in a certain
direction
then that's either immediately visible
or it's quickly findable that's also
what we do here it's
a window where one side is open it's
exactly the dimensions that you can
usually climb through the lamp is on
all the other windows around are closed
and dark you say subtle but i think
that's debatable really
everything in this level is almost
connected to the murder mystery
and every character in this mission is
connected to the murder mystery and we
experimented with
when you walk up the to the mansion or
the detective walks up to the mansion
we really wanted you to be the detective
that meets alexa so
so we kind of had to design that start
of the mission
so that you could become it before that
meeting mr whitmer thank you for coming
on such short notice
a great tragedy has fallen upon us and i
need a quick resolution
architecturally it was designed inside
out everything was designed to be
dense we had this murder mystery as a
central element
that would dictate some characters and
behaviors and what certain rooms would
do
we knew we needed different family
members as a suspect so they needed to
be in areas that were accessible where
there wasn't too much other stuff going
on and where you could clearly see them
they needed to be ideally out in
the middle of open rooms we knew we
needed some rooms that you could search
they needed to be located in a place
where it would be a little hard to get
to but you would still be able to to
reach them without too much difficulty
and they needed to be in their place
where you would expect rooms to be
that kind of dictated how the mansion
ended up being structured in terms of
who
and what was in it we really strive
towards
like each family member should have
their own little biome you have edward
playing piano and and being very nervous
about writing a speech
then you have emma and gregory like
bickering in the
main living room and then you have
patrick who is this like
flirty douchebag
who is a bully i i just think that was
great
that we could get in those personalities
we knew we wanted to present the body
first because that's how you know it's a
it's a locker room murder mystery right
you need to see the body you need to get
concrete and see hey here is a
manifestation of the case you're trying
to solve at the same time starting
with the dead body acts as a tutorial
so that's where we we actually have this
little tutorial message
where diana says hey why don't you scan
the dead body 47
and there's even a ui element on
everything so you learn to use a camera
which is a new feature in hitman 3 if
you've forgotten from the first level it
introduces
going around and interacting with things
to gain intel and that these act as
clues
and it also introduces the idea that
okay now you've found enough clues to
proceed and and then what happens and
that's what's going to happen just on a
larger scale
once you've left that room and talk to
the butler but even before that
we have the butter walk you up to the
roon and underway we deliver
a bucket load of exposition i trust i do
not need to remind you
that there will be consequences if word
gets out that madame carlisle is still
alive
i'll consider her dead when i leave
usually it's uh
really hard to keep the player listening
to one conversation for a long time when
there are so many options
so this whole tour through the mansion
both acts as introduction to the space
and as a as a delivery of exposition and
then once you go down
you talk to the butler you get the last
information you really need and you can
just see all the options that you have
which is
it's something we like to do we like to
surface that hey here are all these
things you could do they're all relevant
and then from there
you're basically free to go in whichever
order you want i worked a lot with the
writer on this you know how
in spy movies or detective movies you
have a clipboard full of notes and then
these red lines and stuff yeah she had
one of those and it was just massive and
uh she would refer to it and go like oh
how does this connect with that and we
tried to string it all together so no
matter how you approached it it would
make sense
and then of course once you have enough
uh evidence
diana hints that you can talk to the
butler you can go back to him and
you get led up to the area where you
were previously trespassing like
everything is made to build up to this
moment where you go
sit down in front of alexa and this is
something that doesn't usually happen in
a hitman level at least not in hitman 1
and 2
that you are actually encouraged to just
sit down in front of the target and talk
to them we build a lot on on this
multiple outcomes and making them all
like so if you've unlocked the
enough clues to make them all available
to you you get the choice of which one
you want just having the choice in there
made it
a little more interactive your niece
emmer carlisle
murdered your brother zachary we used to
have
killing emma for alexa after doing the
murder mystery as
a an optional objective i think it was
even mandatory for a short while
because if she figures out that you're
an assassin and you found out that emma
is
betraying the main target well then it
made sense for her to want her dead and
she
does want that in the current story but
back then she would then ask 47 to kill
her for her i don't suppose i could
convince you to deal with my
daughter-in-law now you're here
this was kind of cool i've seen some
fans commenting on forums that oh
they they wish that was the thing that
seems like a missed opportunity but the
issue was that
the story is very much leading up to
this moment when
diana suddenly cuts out and goes missing
and there's this build up near the exit
point
mission complete well done 47
and all of that stuff would just be kind
of watered down and made
silly if you had just been out running
an errand for the person you were there
to kill anyway
it wasn't really what we were going for
so we had to cut that finding things
in a level that you can do or just fun
things that are there
becomes all the more interesting if you
know that
not everyone will find it and it makes
you all the more curious if you know
that there are probably other things to
find
but you might never find them the fact
that players don't find
everything is kind of gratifying in its
own way i'm very weak for the
the cane the bulldog king because it's a
it's an item
that you can use for melee but you can
also use it
as like a little key
and i think it's like so subtly done and
and
i think it's really cool it really plays
into this like we have a mansion and we
need
secret routes and we have secret routes
which is the bookshelf but then we have
like an additional layer of secrecy
with this like ancient cane that can
open up passageways
if you follow the dialogue and the
actions on the level you can actually
make
one npc kill another and when that
happens when you're listening to some
conversation and then the picture in
picture pops up and you see target
eliminated
the first time if you don't know what
you did that is super fun and then
seeing on the forums people writing
about what happened there and then
trying to
to you know rewind and figure out what
did they do to make that happen then see
oh
right that oh i see if the player does
these weird things that make niche cases
happen then make those niche cases fun
as long as players are having fun i'm
totally fine with them not playing
exactly as i thought they would
we've been watching a lot of streams
like after the release of the game
and and people play so different ways
and we have the chaotic players
uh who who like will do all kinds of
crazy things and kill a lot of people
and i'm like
well they're still having fun the game
design is like
it supports it in some way um so so it
doesn't feel like an exploit kind of
even if you're just going for those very
curated experiences there's always
multiple ways that are worth taking and
it's always worth replaying it to take
them
and then of course you have this this
toolbox of items that you can bring into
the level of find on the level that that
usually do something related to luring
someone somewhere
or triggering something that's where we
discover players doing things that we
never thought they could do
and when that happens then there's a
reason to go back right because you know
that oh
this will afford some combinations that
i hadn't thought of before
so even if you've done all the things
that the developer
thought would be cool to do you can
probably find something that that we
couldn't
possibly predict i think the people who
completed the fastest
in the end are the people who had the
most fun with it overall
i hope at least i think it's cool
because the number of hours that went
into the level before you reached the
point you could complete it in a matter
of seconds
that makes it all worth it right
[Music]
usually when we are two level designers
on a level uh we kind of split up
things for this for example the the
typical example in miami is that
a one level designer had the left side
of the racetrack and the other level
designer have the right side of the race
track
and and that is very like practical
but for this level it was like the
murder mystery was so big and
and uh it kind of
that was my cat um